PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
So we have a fun lecture today
about efficient origami design.
Last Monday, we did
inefficient origami design,
but it was universal.
We could fold anything.
And let's see,
Thursday, we talked
about some basic
foldability, crease patterns,
what make the valid.
That'll ground us
a little bit today
when designing some
crease patterns.
Although, we're going to
stay fairly high level today
because there are two big
methods I want to talk about.
One is tree method
which is hit it pretty
big in the impractical
origami design.
Lot of modern complex
origami designers
use it either in their head
or occasionally on a computer.
I demoed it quickly last time.
So we are going to see some
level of detail how that works.
And then, I want to
talk about Orgamizer
which is one of the latest
techniques for designing
crazy, arbitrary,
three-dimensional shapes that
seems to be pretty efficient.
Although we don't have a formal
sense in which it is efficient,
it has some nice properties.
And it's pretty cool,
and I can also demo it.
It's also freely downloadable
software for Windows.
Good.
So just to get you
motivated a little bit,
I brought a bunch of examples.
I'll show you more later.
But this is the
sort of thing you
can do with the tree method.
It's not going to be the tree
method as I presented here.
This is a variation
on it called box
pleating which
you can read about
in Origami Design Secrets.
And I don't think Jason
will talk about that either.
But it's a variation on
what we'll be talking about.
It lets you do crazy things like
these two praying mantises, one
eating the other.
This is a design by Robert Lang.
Fairly new.
I don't have a year
here, but I think
it's last year or something.
And that's the sort
of thing you can
do getting all the limbs, all
the right proportions, even
multiple characters
by representing
your model as a stick figure.
And that's what
the tree method is
all about and doing
that efficiently.
So this is a statement
last time of the theorem.
There's some catches to this.
It's an algorithm.
Find a folding of
the smallest square
possible into and origami
base with the desired
tree as a shadow
or as a projection.
So you remember,
this kind of picture.
You want to make a lizard.
You specify the lengths
of each of these limbs
and how they're connected
together into a tree.
And then, you want to build an
origami model on top of that,
so to speak.
So that it looks
something like this.
And you want to find a square
the folds into such a shape.
This projection is
exactly that tree.
Now, say it's an algorithm, and
it finds the smallest square.
But to do that, essentially
requires exponential time.
We'll prove in the next class
that this problem, in general,
is NP-complete.
So it's really hard.
But there is an
exponential time algorithm,
and I didn't say efficient here.
It's efficient in terms
of design, quality,
or in terms of algorithm.
But you have to
pick one of the two.
So in TreeMaker the
program, there's
an efficient
algorithm, which finds
a reasonably good-sized square.
But it's not guaranteed
to be optimal.
It's just a local optimum.
In principle, you could
spend exponential time here.
So slow algorithm and
get the smallest square.
So it depends.
The other catch is this folding.
We're still working on proving
that this does not actually
self-intersect in
the folded state.
I checked the dates.
We've been working on
that for six years.
But it's closing in.
Maybe next year we'll have
a draft of this proof.
It's quite-- it's
many, many pages.
Good.
So those are the catches.
Now, let me tell you
about this term uniaxial.
Essentially, it just
means tree shapes.
But I'd like to be a little
bit more formal about that.
And last time, I showed you
the standard origami bases.
All of these are
uniaxial, I think,
except the pinwheel
which we folded.
So the pinwheel-- so let
me tell you intuitively
what uniaxial means.
It means you can take
all these flaps of paper
and lie them, place
them along a line.
And the hinges
between those flaps
are all perpendicular
to that line.
So this is the axis.
Whereas something like
this, essentially there
are four axes.
The flaps are here,
or two axes I guess.
But definitely not one.
So these cannot be
lined up along a line,
even if you've flapped
them around some other way.
That's intuitive definition.
Multiaxial is not a
formally defined thing.
But uniaxial we can
formally define.
And it will capture things
like this water bomb base,
all the other bases there,
as well as bases like this.
And it's defined
by Robert Lang, I
think probably around '94
was the first publication.
And it's just a
bunch of conditions.
And a bunch of them are just
technical to make things work
out mathematically.
First thing I'd like to say
is that the entire base-- base
just means origami
for our purposes.
It's sort of
practical distinction
not a mathematical one.
Is that everything
lies above the floor.
So the floor is equal
to zero, and we'll just
say everything's above that.
And the action is going
to be in the floor.
That's where I've
drawn it that way.
Here, there's a floor.
And the tree is going
to lie on the floor,
and everything
else is above that.
Second property.
Sort of a shadow property.
If I look at where
the base meets
the floor is equals to
zero, that's the same thing
as if I look at the
shadow onto the floor.
This is essentially saying
that this base does not
have any overhang.
So if it had, for
example, some feature
like this that hung over
its shadow-- was more--
went out here.
The shadow goes out here,
but the base does not.
That's not allowed.
So I want everything--
actually want
things to get smaller
as you go up in z.
This is a stronger
statement of property two.
And then, I want to
define this notion flaps.
And the basic idea
is that you have
faces of the crease pattern.
so the faces are
just the regions
we get out of the creases, all
these triangles for example.
I can divide them,
partition them
into groups which I call flaps.
So for example, these two
guys over here form one flap.
They fold together.
They're going to be
manipulated together.
And so in this case,
I'll get four flaps.
Anything I want to say here?
Yeah.
Each flap is going to
project to a line segment.
It's going to be one of
the edges of the tree.
So then, there's the
notion of a hinge crease.
And these are just creases
shared by two flaps.
So they're the creases that
separate one flap from another.
These will always require
that they projects to a point.
So this is equivalent to saying
the hinge crease is vertical.
It's perpendicular to the floor.
I'm always projecting
straight down onto the floor
orthographically, just
setting z to zero.
And so that's saying
these are the hinges.
They should be vertical.
So projection is a point.
And then from those
two properties,
I can define a graph
which I want to be a tree.
So each flap I want to
make an edge of my graph.
And that edge is going
to be the line segment
that the flap projects,
each flat projects to.
And I'm going to connect
those edges together
at vertices when the flaps
share the hinge crease.
All right.
That's a graph which
you can define.
And that graph is a tree.
That's the constraint.
And I think I have even more.
I've got one more property.
I think I actually
want projects here.
Let's try that.
All right.
This is a bunch of formalism to
state what's pretty intuitive.
I want all the flaps of
paper to be vertical,
so they project
to a line segment.
When I look from the-- when
I look at the projection,
I can define a
graph where there's
an edge for each flap,
where it's projecting.
And I join those edges together.
Here, I'm joinging
four them at a vertex.
Because if you unfold it,
they all share hinge creases.
Hinge creases in this case
are the perpendicular.
These four guys.
So because-- it's
hard to manipulate.
I've got a flap over here.
A flap over here.
They share a hinge, so I connect
them together in the graph.
It's just a formal way to
make the graph correct.
It may seem tedious,
but this definition
sidesteps some issues which
would occur if you defined it
in the more obvious way which
is just take the projection,
call it a tree.
But I don't want
to get into why you
need to do it this way exactly.
Maybe, we'll see
it at some point.
Essentially, some flaps can
be hidden inside others,
so you need this definition
for it to really work.
And then, there's
this extra constraint
which is that my base
is pointy at the leaves.
Leaves are the
vertices of the tree
to have only one incident edge.
And so I want there
to be only one
point that lives at the leaf.
Obviously, elsewhere
in the tree,
there's a whole bunch of points,
a whole vertical segment,
that all projects to that point.
Here, I just want one.
That's important
because I want to think
about where the leaves are.
And the whole idea
in the tree method
is to think about how to
place the leaves on your piece
of paper so that
this folding exists.
So that's what
we're going to do.
The tree method is kind of
surprising in its simplicity.
There's a bunch of
details to make it work.
But the idea is
actually very simple.
Let's suppose you want
ability uniaxial base.
I'll tell you something
that must be satisfied
by your uniaxial base,
a necessary condition.
Assuming you're starting from
a convex piece of paper, which
is the case we
usually care about.
Actually, we're starting
from a square, a rectangle,
or something convex.
Here's what has to be true.
I didn't give a
name, but this graph
that's supposed
to be a tree, I'm
going to call the shadow
tree for obvious reasons.
And now, I want to take two
points in the shadow tree,
measure their distance
in a tree sense.
So I have some tree like this.
I have two points like, say,
this point and that point.
The distance between
them is the distance as
measured if you had to walk
in the tree, how far is it
to go from here to here.
And because our tree
is a metric tree,
because we specified
all the edge lengths,
we can just add up those
lengths, measure them.
And that's the distance
between two points in the tree.
That must be less than
or equal to the distance
between those two points
on the piece of paper.
What does that mean?
So on piece of paper
that's convex--
so it might not be a square, but
square's easier picture draw.
The distance between
them is that.
Pretty simple.
So what does this mean?
I'm taking this square.
Somehow, I'm folding
it into a base
whose projection is the tree.
So I look at these
two points, p and q,
I fold them somewhere
in the 3D picture
which is not drawn up here.
Those points-- so maybe there's
a p up here and a q up here.
I project those points
down onto the floor which
is going to fall on the
tree by this definition.
Call that, let's say, p prime
for the projected version of p,
q prime.
I measure the distance here.
That has to be-- the
distance between p prime
and q prime in
the tree should be
less than or equal to the
distance between p and q
in the piece of paper, for
every pair points p and q.
That's the condition.
It's almost trivial
to show because when
I take this segment of paper,
I fold the piece of paper.
But in particular, I
fold p and q somehow.
I can't get p and q farther
away from each other
because folding only
makes things closer.
There, I'm assuming that the
piece of paper is convex.
There's no way to
fold and stretch pq
because that's a
segment of paper.
It can only contract.
I mean, you can fold the
segment something like this.
Then, the distance
between p and q
gets smaller than the
length of this segment.
Because if I took this-- this
line segment of paper that got
folded.
If I project it
onto the line here,
it's only going to get shorter.
So I fold p and q.
They get closer in three-space.
And then, I project
them down to the floor.
They can also only get
closer when I do that.
So that's essentially the proof.
Do I need to spell that out?
So you have the line
segment on the paper.
You fold it.
It gets shorter.
You project it onto the floor.
It also get shorter.
Therefore, whatever
this distance
is on the tree has to be less
than or equal to the distance
you started with.
So this may seem
kind of trivial.
But the surprising thing is it
this is really all you need.
So this is true between any
two points in the shadow tree.
In fact, we're going
to focus on the leaves.
We'll say, all right,
so in particular, I've
got a place this leaf, and
each of these six leaves here,
I have to place them somewhere
on the piece of paper.
I better do it so that that
condition is satisfied.
I have to place these two
leaves and the piece of paper--
let's say this distance is
one, and this distance is one.
These two leaves have to be
placed on the piece of paper
such that their distance
is at least two.
And the distance between these
two guys has to be at least two
and between these two guys
has to be at least two.
And same over here.
Let's say all the
edge lengths are one.
And the distance between,
say, this leaf and this leaf
has to be at least three
because the distance in the tree
is three.
So at the very least, we should
place the points on the paper
so that those conditions
are satisfied,
and it turns out,
that's enough as long
as you find a placement of the
points such as those conditions
are satisfied.
There will be a folding where
those leaves actually come
from those points of paper.
That's the crazy part.
But this idea is actually
kind of obvious in some sense.
I mean, once you know
it, it's really obvious.
But what's surprising is it this
is all you need to worry about.
There's a lot of details that
make that work, but you can.
So let me just
mention one detail
which is the scale factor.
If you fix the size,
the edge lengths
on the tree which
is the usual, which
is one way to think
about it, and you
start with some square--
like if I start with a one
by one square, there's no way
I'm going to fold that tree.
There's just not enough
distance in the square.
So what I'd like to do is
find the smallest square
that can fold into this thing.
Or equivalently find--
you can think of scaling
the piece of paper, or
the tree with a
fixed piece of paper.
Doesn't really matter.
In general, you get
this problem which
I'll call scale optimization.
This is the hard problem.
So let's say-- just
defining some variables.
So P i, I'm going to
maybe number the leaves
or label label them
somehow, various letters.
And then, P i is going
to be the point where
that-- of paper
that actually forms
that leaf in the folded state.
That leaf which corresponds
to a single point of paper
projects to that leaf.
And then, my goal is
to maximize some scale
factor which I'll call lambda.
Subject to a bunch of
constraints which are just
those constraints, except
that I add a scale factor.
So for every pair
of leaves, i and j,
I'm going to
measure the distance
between those
leaves in the tree.
This as a tree distance.
Compare that to the
distance and the piece
of paper between those two
points, the Euclidean distance.
And instead of
requiring that this
is greater than or equal to
this, which is the usual one,
I'm going to add in
the scale factor which
you can think of as shrinking
this or expanding that.
It doesn't matter.
But I want to-- because here I'm
sort of shrinking this amount.
I want to maximize
that factor, so I
shrink it the least possible.
You can formulate it this way
or maybe a more intuitive way.
But this is the standard set up.
And this is something-- this is
called a nonlinear optimization
problem.
It's something that lots
of people think about.
There are heuristics
to solve it.
You can solve in an
exponential time.
In general, it's
NP-complete, and we'll
see next class that actually
this problem of origami design
is NP-complete.
So there's not going to be
anything better than heuristics
and and slow algorithms.
So the idea is, you solve that.
Now, you have your leaves on
your piece of paper somewhere.
Now what?
Now, you have to figure
out how everything folds.
That's where we get to
some real combinatorial,
some discrete geometry.
Fun stuff.
Yeah.
I have one extra
motivation here.
Origami design is
fun, but here's
a puzzle you can solve, too.
Which we can already see.
Margulis napkin problem.
Origin of this problem
is not entirely clear,
but I think it came
from Russia originally.
And the problem, the puzzle
is usually stated as follows.
Prove that if you take
a unit square paper--
so it has perimeter
four that you can,
no matter how you fold it, the
perimeter always gets smaller.
Never bigger than four.
We used a very
similar thing here.
We said, if you have
two points, they're
distance can only get smaller.
That's true.
Margulis napkin
puzzle is not true.
That's the difference.
Perimeter is different
from distance.
And in fact, you can
fold a piece of paper
to make the perimeter
arbitrarily large,
which is pretty crazy.
And this is something
that Robert Lang
proved few years ago, using--
It's sort of easy once
you have the fact-- which
I haven't quite written down
here, but I've been saying.
As long as you place your
points subject to this property,
there is a folding that
has that shadow tree.
And so the idea with the
Margulis napkin problem
is let's make a really
spiky tree, a star.
I want to fold the
smallest square possible,
so that projection
is this thing.
Let's say that it has-- I won't
say how many limbs it has.
But the idea is, if you're using
paper efficiently, in fact,
the folding will be very narrow.
It'll be a pretty efficient
use of paper, hopefully.
And so the actual
3D state will just
be a little bit
taller than that tree.
And then, you just wash it.
And the idea is that then
the perimeter is really big.
You've got a-- the
perimeter as you
walk around the
edges of that tree.
So how big a tree can I get?
I'd like to somehow
place these leaves-- now,
what's the constraint
on the leaves?
Let's say all of
these are length one.
Then, this says it
every pair of leaves
must be at least distance
two way from each other.
So I got to place these
dots in the square
so that every pair has
distance at least two.
This is like saying--
here's my square.
--I'd like to place dots
so their distance is
at least distance two.
That's like saying
if, I drew a unit
disk around two points--
I got to remember.
You should always draw the
disk first and then the center.
Much easier.
Those disks should
not be overlapping.
If this is length one,
and this is length one,
the disks will be
overlapping if and only
if this distance is
smaller than two.
I want it always to be
greater than or equal to two.
So I just have to place a whole
bunch of disks in the square
so that they're not overlapping.
So how big a square
do I need to do that?
This is a well-studied problem,
is the disk packing problem.
A lot of results known about it.
It's quite difficult.
But we don't need to be super
smart here to get a good bound.
Let's put a point-- let's
put points along a grid.
I'm going to regret
making such a big grid.
Let's say, an n by n grid.
And I'm going to set
the size of my disks
right so that these
guys just barely touch.
This is actually not a
terribly good packing.
You should do a triangular
grid instead of a square grid.
But it'll be good
enough asymptotically.
You get the idea.
If I set the size of
my paper to be n by n,
I can fit about n squared
unit disks in there.
N by n paper folds something
like n plus 1 squared.
But let's just say,
approximately n squared disks.
So that means I can make a star
with about n squared limbs.
It's insane.
It's like super efficient.
Each of these little
portions of paper
ends up being one
of these segments.
That's the claim is,
you could fold that.
So once you fold this thing,
I have an n by n square.
You started with
perimeter about four n
And now, I have perimeter
about n squared.
That's huge with
respect to four n.
So this is much bigger than four
n, for n sufficiently large.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
about the length flaps.
PROFESSOR: Here, I was assuming
all the flaps are length one.
So the disks are size one,
and so it's an n by n square.
Clear?
So this is more
motivation for why
this theorem is interesting.
It lets you solve
this fun math puzzle
and show not only does a
perimeter not go-- not only
does the perimeter
not only go down,
but it can go arbitrarily high.
It just takes a lot of folding.
So let's say
something about how we
prove that once you have a
valid placement of the points,
you can actually fill in
the creases, find folding.
Let me bring up an example.
So this is actually
the example I
keep using which is, you
want to make a lizard
or some generic four-legged
tail and head kind of creature.
This is the output
from TreeMaker,
complete with crease
pattern and everything.
But here, I've labeled
all the-- or actually
Robert Lang, I think, has
labeled all of-- this a figure
from our book.
--all the vertices of
the tree and the shadow.
And then, we're
labeling where they
come from on the piece of paper.
So in particular, you see
something like a leaf h.
And it comes from this
one point on the paper.
This leaf d comes
from this point,
and g comes from that point.
It's actually kind of
similarly oriented to this guy.
The interior vertices, they
come from several points.
It's a little messy.
But let's-- one of the things
is to try to locate where those
points ought to be.
s So there's this idea
of an active path which
is a path in the tree
between two leaves.
I'll call them
shadow leaves to say
that they're in the shadow tree.
And the length of
that path equals
the distance in the paper.
So in the case of
making a star graph,
this is exactly
when the disks kiss,
when the just touch each
other on the boundary.
So in other words, we
have this inequality,
saying the distance
between in the paper should
be greater than or equal
to distance in the tree.
If that inequality is
actually an equality,
if they're the same thing,
then it's kind of critical.
I can't get those points
any closer in the paper.
Those things I
call active paths.
And that is some of
the lines up here.
I guess the black
dashed line, actually,
in a lot of the dash lines.
All of the dash lines, I think.
So for example, d to h, that's
a distance between two leaves.
And if you measure the
distance here, it's two.
And just imagine,
this example has
been set up so this
is exactly two.
So this is tight.
I can't move h any closer
to d or vice versa.
And also from h to
a, a is actually
in the middle of the paper
and corresponds to that flap.
That's all of those
green, actually
it's just the green lines,
green dashed lines are active.
They're kind of critical.
And what's nice is that
subdivides my piece of paper
into a bunch of smaller shapes.
So I have a little
triangle out here.
That turns out to be junk.
We're not going to need
it because the sort
of outside the diagram.
You could folder underneath.
Get rid of it.
You've got a quadrilateral
here between the green lines.
We've got a triangle
up here, a triangle
at the top, triangle
on the left.
All we need to do is fill
in those little parts.
Fill in that triangle.
Fill in that quadrilateral.
Of course, in general, there
might not be any active paths,
and we haven't simplified
the diagram at all.
But if there are
no active paths,
you're really probably
not very efficient.
That means none of these
constraints are tight.
That means you could increase
the scale factor lambda,
make a better model.
You can increase lambda
at least a little bit.
If all of these are
strictly greater,
you can increase lambda until
one of them becomes equal.
So you should have at
least one active path.
And in fact if
you're efficient, you
should have lots
of active paths.
I don't think I need to
be too formal about that.
But it's true.
And here's one thing you
can show about active paths.
So what would be really
nice, in this example,
I have triangles
and quadrilaterals.
In general, I'm going
to have a whole bunch
of different shapes.
Some of them could
even be non-convex
which would be annoying.
I would really just like
to deal with triangles
because I like
triangles-- geometer.
And triangles are simple.
And it looks like the
crease pattern in a triangle
is pretty simple.
In fact, it's just
angular bisectors
of the triangle plus a few
extra perpendicular folds.
So that would be
kind of nice if I
could get everything triangles.
To do that, I need
lots of active paths.
So how can I guarantee that
there's lots of active paths?
I'm going wave my hands a little
bit about how this is done.
But the idea is to
augment the tree.
So I have some tree that
I actually want to make,
like lizard.
And I'm going to add
some extra stuff.
Like maybe I'll add a branch
here and a branch here
or whatever.
Whatever it takes.
I got to do so carefully.
So let me say what that means.
So I'm going to add extra
leaves to the shadow tree.
My goal is to make the active
paths triangulate the paper
without changing
the scale factor.
So this is kind of a cheat.
And most of the time, you
don't actually need this cheat.
But for proving things, it
makes life a little easier.
So we want to show that
it's enough to place
the vertices subject
to this, the leaves
subject to this constraint.
So ideally, we make our tree.
But if we make an even
more complicated tree,
like with these extra little
limbs, we can get rid of them
at the end.
You just fold them
over and collapse
this flap against
an adjacent flap.
So if we make our life
harder, that's OK, too.
If we could fold a
more complicated tree,
in particular we folded
the tree we wanted.
If we can do that without
changing the scale factor,
then great.
Then, we did what
we wanted to do.
We folded our piece of paper
with the desired scale factor.
In reality, we're actually
going to move the leaves
around a little bit
so that we have to do.
We're going to move
around the leaves
that you already placed
in order to make room
for the new leaves.
But here's the idea.
We have these leaves.
There's some active
paths, these green lines.
And we'd really-- we have this
quadrilateral in the center.
We'd really like
to subdivide it.
Like this black line is
kind of asking for it.
It would be really
nice if we could just
add in an active paths there.
And you can do it.
Let's see if I can identify
what we're talking about here.
So a fun thing
about active paths,
you look at two leaves like
g d here, which corresponds
to this path g d here,
because it's active,
you know this length is exactly
the length traced right here.
So that means, this
segment has to be
folded right along
the tree here.
You know that this
segment is that.
And so in particular, you know
where c is on that segment.
C actually comes from multiple
points in this diagram.
But you know that this point
right here must fold to c.
And you know this point
must fold here and so on.
These guys correspond.
So that's good.
So if I look at
this quadrilateral,
it corresponds so g to c to d
to c to h to c to b to a back
to b back to c.
And so my guess is if you
add a little limb in here--
I think I can draw on this.
That would be nice.
Should really tell you
about-- is this going to work?
Yes.
It's kind of white,
but there we go.
So great.
Draw a fun diagram here.
This is how I make my lecture
notes if you're curious.
This is a tablet PC.
Now, I've got
some-- Tell me if I
make a mistake, those who
know what I'm drawing.
What the hell is this?
I think it goes there.
There.
I'll explain what I'm
drawing once I've drawn it.
It's easier.
Something like that.
This is a bunch of disks
and a bunch of other things,
there's only one
here called rivers.
And this is a geometric way to
think about the constraints.
If you look at this structure--
so I have a disk down
here corresponding to d.
I have a disk corresponding
to h, a disk corresponding
to g, a river corresponding
to the segment b c.
The reason I only
have one river is
there's only one interior
edge in this tree.
Everything else is a leaf edge.
So leaf edges are
going to be disks.
All non leaf edges are
going to be rivers.
And the structure, the way
that those things connect
to each other is the same as
the structure in this tree.
So you've got the
three disks down here,
which corresponds
to these leaf edges.
They all touch a common river
because all of those edges
are incident to that
edge in the center.
And there's three
disks on the top that
correspond to the three
leaf edges up here.
This is really just
the same thing.
It's saying that if
you want to look, say,
at the distance
between h and a here.
The distance between h and
a should be length three.
And those three
lengths are represented
by the size of
this disk, followed
by the width of
this river, followed
by the size of the a disk.
It's say exactly the same
constraints, just represented
geometrically.
Now, if I'm lucky,
these regions actually
kiss, they touch at points.
That's when things are active.
And you could draw straight
across from a to h and never go
in these outside regions.
If you're not lucky,
they won't touch.
If they don't touch,
make them touch.
That's all I want to do.
And so I just want to
blow up these regions,
make them longer, for
example, until things touch.
When they touch enough,
if you do it right,
you can actually get
them to triangulate.
That's my very
hand wavy argument.
It's proved formally
in the book,
and it's a little bit technical.
So I think I will
move on and tell you
what to do with triangles.
So suppose you
have some triangle.
And each of these edges
is an active path.
So there's some leaf here.
We'll call them a, b, and c.
And this segment we know will
map right along the floor
to make up that path, that
active path in the tree.
Like I said, we're going to
follow along angular bisectors.
You may know the angular
bisectors of a triangle
meet at a single point.
And then, we're going to
make some perpendicular
folds like that.
Where the
perpendicular folds go,
well, they go whenever
there's a shadow
vertex along this segment.
Remember this edge,
b c corresponds
to some path between b
and c in the tree which
looks like whatever.
And so for each
of these branching
points that we visit along
that, we can just measure.
As we move along here, we get to
some vertex then another vertex
then another vertex then c,
except I did it backwards.
And so for each of
these guys, I know
that I need to be able
to articulate there.
I need a hinge crease.
And so I just put in a
hinge grace perpendicular
to the floor,
essentially, because we
know this is mapping
to the floor.
And conveniently,
those will all line up.
So if I have some vertex
here-- let's call it d.
--d will be here.
But d will also be here.
Because if I follow
the path from b to a,
a is some other
guy, maybe this one,
I also have to go through d.
And so these things will
conveniently line up perfectly.
I'm not going to
prove that again.
But it's true.
And you just get this really
nice simple to fold thing.
Shoot, I'll fold
one if you haven't.
This is a standard rabbit ear
molecule in making origami.
You have a little triangle.
You want to make it an ear.
You squeeze along the
angular bisectors,
and it makes a cute rabbit ear.
And you can see it also,
the crease pattern,
in here like in this
triangle in the upper right.
You've got the red lines which
are the angular bisectors.
And then, you've got all
those perpendicular folds.
And they go exactly
where those letters go.
And the triangle at
the top is similar.
It's a little different because
the very top edge of the paper
is not actually active.
So there's really a
special case there.
Upper right is also not active.
Oh, that's annoying.
Yeah.
There's a little
bit of extra stuff
that happens at the
boundary of the paper
where you don't
have active paths.
But it's, as you can see
from the crease pattern,
it's basically the same.
In fact, I could
call it the same.
It's a little bit less pretty
because this is not green.
And so you don't actually
know that c is here.
And you don't know
that b is there.
But you know about
all the other edges.
There's just one edge
you might not know about.
And so you can figure
out what the right edge
is based on the other edges
of the triangle, the other two
edges.
That's just a feature.
You can triangulate everything
except the boundary.
You may not be able to get
active paths in this step.
That kind of does
the tree method
in a super abbreviated version.
I showed you a demo last
time, just in case you forgot.
You draw your favorite tree.
See if I can get it
to do the same one.
And you optimize,
generate a crease pattern.
Oh, it's a different one.
Fun.
There it is.
And here, TreeMaker knows
how to draw the disks.
It doesn't currently know how
to draw the rivers because it's
kind of tricky to make a snakey
path in a computer program.
But you see the three disks down
here, the three disks up there,
and you can imagine
the one river
in the middle representing the
central segment of your tree.
And one of the problems
on the problems set,
problem set one is
released, is to just make
something using TreeMaker.
I would encourage
you to start simple
unless you know
what you're doing.
You don't have to
use the program.
You could do it by
hand, placing disks.
That's how most
origamists actually do it.
I'm sure Jason will
do it that way.
You can use the program,
print out a crease pattern,
see what it looks like.
Next thing.
If you want to do
this in reality--
and what TreeMaker is doing
is not this triangulation.
Doing a triangulation
is a bit of a pain,
but you could keep
modifying your tree
until it triangulates.
The alternative is you
just deal with polygons
that are bigger than triangles.
And there's this thing
called the universal molecule
by Robert Lang.
Here it is for a quadrilateral.
And it makes it-- this works
for any convex polygon.
Now sometimes, you're
active paths don't decompose
your shape into convex polygons.
And this still doesn't work.
You still have to
do something here.
You need to add some
extra leaf edges
to the tree to just
fill things up.
But you don't have to stop.
You have to go all the way to
the point of triangulation.
You can stop at the point which
happens most the time when
all of the faces are convex.
And then, it's a slightly more
general picture what happens.
Intuitively, what
you want to do is,
this is the tree you want
to make among those leaves.
All the boundary edges
here are active paths.
You have g d h a.
Those are active
paths, so you know
where all of those branching
points are in the middle.
You'd like to build that.
And so what we're going to
do is build it bottom up
in the literal sense from z
equals zero, increasing z.
And what that corresponds
to in this picture
is shrinking or offsetting
these edges inward.
So you offset these
all by the same amount.
That's like traveling
up over here.
So you see the red
lines here correspond
to the red cross sections.
So I just see what happens
in cross section is
I shrink things in.
And the first thing that happens
at this first critical red
drawing is that the path
from d to a becomes critical,
becomes active.
Before it was
inactive that-- that
was kind of annoying for me.
I wanted it to be
triangulated, but it wasn't.
The distance from a to
d in the piece of paper
was bigger than the distance
between the leaves in the tree.
I wanted them to be equal.
Well, it turns out, if
you shrink this thing,
eventually they
might become equal.
And that's what happens.
And that's what
TreeMaker computes.
And what you should
do if you're building
the universal molecule.
If you discover, oh,
now a d is active,
now, I subdivide
into two triangles.
And then, I do the thing
in the two triangles.
And generally, you start
with some convex polygon.
You shrink it.
At some point, some diagonal
might become active.
You split it into two,
just keep going in the two.
And there's one other
thing which can happen,
which is what's happening
at the end of a triangle.
You shrink.
And then, it could be two
vertices actually collide
with each other.
And then, you just think
of them as one vertex
and keep shrinking.
So that's the general universal
molecule construction.
You see in a sort of-- these are
the cross sections from above.
You see that as you go up,
things are getting smaller.
That is one of the statements of
the uniaxial base as you go up.
Cross sections get tinier.
And that gives you
the crease pattern.
If you follow along
where the vertices go
during this process,
and you draw in
and all the active path that
you create along the way,
that's your crease pattern.
So that's how you do
it more practically is
you use the universal molecule.
But to prove it, you
don't actually need that.
All right.
I have now some more real
examples by Robert Lang
and by Jason Ku.
So here is Roosevelt elk.
And Rob is all about
getting very realistic form.
So all of the branching
measurements and-- I'm
sure if you knew
a lot about elks,
you could recognizes
this a Roosevelt
elk not some other elk.
And you can achieve that
level of detail and realism
using the tree
method because you
can control all of the relative
lengths of those segments
and get perfect
branching structure
and get the right proportions
for the legs and tail
and so on.
And you can see
here, the-- and you
can go to Robert Lang's webpage,
landorigami.com and print this
out.
And try it out if you want.
This will fold not this but
the base for that model.
And you could see the disks.
And you can see some
approximation of the rivers
here.
But they're not quite drawn
in in this particular diagram.
But a lot of detail.
And if you look
carefully, you can really
read off what the tree is here.
You can see how these
things are separated,
and it will correspond to the
branching structure over there.
Here's a more complicated one.
Scorpion varleg
which you can also
fold at lifesize if
you're really crazy.
And you can also see from
these kinds of diagrams
that paper usage is super
efficient in these designs.
And presumably that's
how Robert design them.
The only paper we're
wasting in some sense
is the little regions between
the disks and the rivers
which is quite small.
Most of the papers getting
absorbed into the flaps.
Here's one of the first
models by Jason Ku that I saw,
the Nazgul from
Lord of the Rings.
And pretty complicated.
So here, the bold lines
show you essentially
where the disks and the
rivers are that have been--
AUDIENCE: Those are
actually the hinge creases.
PROFESSOR: Oh, those
are hinge creases.
Yeah.
Good.
And the top is the
actual crease pattern.
And it's pretty awesome.
You've got a horse and rider
out of one square paper.
Here's a shrimp.
He's super complicated
and super realistic.
It looks very shrimpy.
I know some people who
are freaked out by shrimp.
And so this should really
elicit that similar response.
Or other people get really
hungry at this point, I guess.
But you could see the
tree is pretty dense here,
lots of little features
getting that branching right.
And one last example
is this butterfly
which is pretty
awesome in its realism.
And I guess the tree
is a lot simpler here.
But there's a lot of
extra creases here.
You see just for getting
the flaps nice and narrow.
So in general, these
kinds of constructions
will make this guy
rather pointy and tall.
And you can just squash it back.
And it's called a
sync fold and make
it tinier like-- you
have something like this.
The flaps are you
think are too tall.
You just fold here.
Which, if you look at
the crease pattern,
makes just an offset
version of the original.
And hey, now your
flaps are half is tall.
And if you're a
proper origamist,
you-- I shouldn't do this live.
You change the mountain valley
assignment a little bit,
and you sync everything
on the inside
instead of just folding it over.
It's not going to
look super pretty.
But same tree structure, just
the flaps are half as tall.
So that's all this
pleating here.
And I think that's it
for my little tour.
And Jason Ku next.
Next Monday we'll
be talking more
about the artistic side,
history of origami design,
and what it takes to
really make something
real by these approaches.
That should be lots of fun.
I want to move on to other kinds
of efficient origami design.
Less directly applicable
to real origami design
so to speak, at least currently.
But mathematically
more powerful.
Uniaxial bases are
nice, but it's not
everything you
might want to fold.
So what if we want
to fold other stuff.
And to a geometer,
most natural version
of folding other stuff
or folding anything
is a polyhedron.
You have a bunch of
polygons, flat panels in 3D,
somehow joined together
to make some surface.
How do I fold that?
And let's start with a super
simple example which is I
want to fold a
square into a cube.
How big a square do I
need to fold a unit cube?
Or how big cube can I
fold for a unit square?
Either way.
And I'm going to make
it a one by one square.
And I'm going to fold it
into a cube of dimension x.
And I want to know--
it looks funny.
It's the quintuple x cubed.
It's the x-coordinate.
That's my motivation.
So we talked-- one
thing we can think about
is what makes the
corners of the cubes
and how far away should they be.
So if I want to fold
this cube, I look at,
let's say, the opposite
corners of the cube.
They're pretty far
away on the cube.
And I know that by
folding I could only
make distance is smaller.
So somehow, if I measure the
shortest path on the cube,
from this point to
this point, it's
that if you believe-- when
you unfold this thing,
it should be flat.
If I unfolds to just
those two squares,
it's a straight line
between the two.
And so that goes to the
midpoint of this edge
and then over there.
And you measure that length.
And oh, trigonometry.
Root five, that's
not what I wanted.
So we have x here, 2x here.
So this distance
is-- yeah, I see.
Why is that different from
what I have written down?
Because that was not the
diameter of the cube.
I see.
AUDIENCE: You want
them equidistant.
PROFESSOR: No.
I do want this but,
I think if I go
from the center of this
square-- this is hard to draw.
--to the center of the back
square, which is back here,
that distance is going
to be wrapping around.
Which is just going
to be like 2x.
Is that bigger or
smaller than root 5x?
AUDIENCE: It's smaller.
PROFESSOR: Smaller.
Interesting.
One, two, three, four.
What did I do wrong?
Oh, I see.
OK.
Here's a fun fact.
This is actually the
smallest antipodal distance.
Get this right.
So if you take some
point on the cube,
and you look at the
point farthest away
from it on the other
side of the cube,
it will always be
at least 2x away.
So here, it's bigger.
This is probably the diameter.
It's bigger than 2x, but it
will always be at least 2x away.
This is actually the smallest
situation you can get.
And so I want to think
about the point that
corresponds to the
center of the square.
Right?
Yes.
Now maybe that maps to
the center like this.
And the antipodal points is
2x away, or maybe it's bigger.
But at least I know that this
length is greater than or equal
to 2x because that's-- the
antipodal point has to be made
from that.
I need to think
about all situation
because I really want to think
about the center of the square.
Once that is at
least 2x, then I know
that the side of the square
is at least 2 root 2x.
Yes.
And so I know that this is one.
And you work it out.
And x is root 2 over 4.
Or it's at most that.
And so that gives you some
bound on what it takes.
So this is actually
really the only technique
we know to prove lower
bounds on how much-- how big
a square you need
to make something.
It's this kind of distance
increasing argument.
And it turns out you can
actually achieve x equals this.
So this is what I
call lower bound.
It says, you can't do
any better than this.
But there's also a matching
upper bound which achieves this
and not going to
draw it perfectly.
So there are the six
sides of the cube.
You've got one, two,
three, four, five.
And the sixth one is
split into quarters.
And you can see, you just
actually fold here, here,
here, and here to get
rid of that excess.
And it will come
together as a cube.
You also fold along
the edges of the cube.
And it perfectly
achieves this property.
That from the
center of the paper,
you have exactly one
this distance 2 root
2x to the antipodal
point which is
the center of the opposite face.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Can you explain where the
2x came from [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I wave my hands.
So I'm thinking
about an arbitrary
point on the
surface of the cube.
Here, it should
be clear it's 2x.
There's x right here.
And there's 1/2x here.
And there's 1/2x on the back.
And I looked at
another situation
which is when it was at a
corner that bigger than 2x.
And I claim if you
interpolate in the middle,
you'll get something
in the middle,
in between 2x and root 5x.
For example, if
take a point here
that's closer to the
corner, then that
point-- you should probably
also think about the edge case.
But you check all of them,
and they're at least 2x.
That's what I'm claiming.
So I didn't really
prove that formally.
But claim is 2x is the smallest
antepodal pair you could get.
AUDIENCE: What does
antipodal mean?
PROFESSOR: Antipodal simple
means on the other side.
The anti pode, the opposite
pole, like from North Pole
to South Pole.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right
now, we know we're
taking whatever point is
the center of the square.
It maps somewhere in the cube.
I take the antipode from there.
I know that has to
be at least 2x away.
And if you look at
the distance map here,
the farthest away point in
the squared from the center
is the corner point.
So I know that that distance
can only get smaller.
And other distances
only get smaller.
So if I have to make a
2x distance from there,
this is my best
chance for doing it.
And that gives
you a lower bound.
Doesn't mean it can be achieved.
But this shows you that
you can achieve it.
This is a result by Catalano,
Johnson, and Lobe in 2001.
It's like the only optimality
result we have for folding 3D
shapes.
That's why I mention it.
Tons of fun open
problems like you
don't want to make
a square-- a cube.
Maybe you want to
make a triangle.
If you want to cover a
triangle on both sides,
that's probably open.
If you want to make
regular tetrahedron,
that's probably open.
Pretty much any problem
you pose here is open.
It would make fun project.
You can also think
about, instead
of starting from
square, you start
with a rectangle of
some given aspect ratio.
What's the biggest
cube you can make?
That's kind of fun
because in the limit
for a super long rectangle,
you should do strip wrapping.
For a square, we have
the right answer.
What's the right
answer in between?
Who knows.
The next thing I wanted to
talk about where there's
been some recent progress
is checkerboard folding.
In lecture one, I showed
you this model which I never
go anywhere without,
the four by four
checkerboard folded from one
square paper, white on one side
and red on the other.
And so I think this is
probably the most efficient way
to fold a four by
four checkerboard.
You start with a
square of one size,
and you shrink both
dimensions by two.
And you get a four
by four checkerboard.
But we don't know
if this is the best
way to fold a checkerboard.
Be nice to know.
And this has been
studied for a while.
And this is not
the standard method
for folding a checkerboard.
But it's actually
pretty efficient
which is kind of crazy.
So you take a
square, white on one
side and brown on the other.
You do this accordion pleat.
You get a bunch of nice color
reversals, bunch of squares.
And then, you just need to make
a square of squares from that.
So general problem is, I want
to fold an n by n checkerboard
from the smallest
possible square.
How big does it have to
be as a function of n?
And the standard
approach is-- well,
this is the first
method that does it
for all n in a
general simple way.
But the practical
foldings people
have designed, like four by four
and there are a bunch of eight
by eights out there, are little
more efficient than this.
But they have the
same asymptotics
which is the perimeter
of the square you start
with has to be about
twice n squared
to make an n by n checkerboard.
And the reason
that is, is if you
look at the
checkerboard pattern,
we're trying to get
color reversals along all
of these lines between the red
and the white, brown and white.
And the way we're doing
that here is we're
taking the boundary
of the paper,
and we're mapping it along
all the color reversals.
And if you work out how
much color reversal is there
in an n by n thing, it's
about twice n squared.
And so either your perimeter
has to be at least that large
if you're going to cover the
color reversals with perimeter.
And for a long time, we thought
that was the best we could do
was to cover color reversals
with a perimeter of paper.
Of course, know that you
can take a square of paper
make the perimeter
arbitrarily large.
So this was never
really a lower bound.
We never really knew that
you needed 2n squared.
The four by four
achieves 2n squared.
We think it's the
best for four by four,
but we proved last
year-- this is
with Marty and [INAUDIBLE]
and Robert Lang--
that you can do better and
get perimeter about n squared.
Now, there are some lower order
terms there, the order n parts.
So this is really only
practical for large n.
I think-- I'll elaborate on
that a little more in a moment.
But here's the idea.
Instead of visiting
all the boundaries
between red and
white squares, I just
want to visit the
squares themselves.
So if I could fold
a, in this case
a rectangle paper
into this shape
which has slits down
the sides, and it
has these flaps hanging out.
Now, you've seen how to make
flaps super efficiently.
You really don't need
to shrink the paper
by very much to
make this pattern.
Then, you take these guys-- and
everything is white side up.
You take these flaps,
fold them over.
They become brown.
And these guys fall over.
These fall down.
These guys fall up.
You can actually make any
two color pixel pattern
from this idea.
And it will make white squares
on top of the brown surface
that you folded.
So this is the starting point.
You just fold everything over.
And you get your checkerboard.
And now, essentially, you're
visiting each square only once
instead of the boundary
edge for all the squares.
And so you end up
using only n squared
instead of twice n squared.
And you can do it if you
start from a square also.
You just need more flaps.
And there's a bunch of
tabs sticking up here,
and a bunch of tabs
sticking up there.
You can fold this again
super efficiently,
using all these
standard techniques.
And then, you make a
checkerboard twice as
efficient for large n as we've
previously thought possible.
Now, we still don't know
whether this is optimal.
We think it is.
But we thought so before also.
Who knows?
So big open problem is
[INAUDIBLE] for anything.
In terms of actual values
of n, for n bigger than 16,
this method is better than
the standard approach.
Although if you look just
at seamless-- so seamless,
I didn't mention,
but we're going
to talk about it
more in a moment.
When I make a square
of a checkerboard,
I'd really like this to
be a single panel of paper
not divided into little panels.
And like in this checkerboard,
this white square
has a bunch of seems on it.
It's made out of three
smaller triangles.
And that's not so nice.
This method is seamless.
You get whole panels making
each of your squares,
so it looks a little prettier.
If you look at the best eight
by eight seamless folding,
this beats the best seamless
eight by eight folding.
Although it's rather
difficult to fold.
Hasn't yet been folded.
That would be a
good project also.
Build an actual checkerboard
with this method.
Questions?
Now, I want to move
to the general case.
So I talked a little bit about
checkerboards and about cubes.
Let's think about
arbitrary polyhedra.
And this is the Origamizer.
So Origamizer's
actually two things.
It's a computer program for
Windows that you can download,
and it's an algorithm.
And they're not quite the same.
So there's original
computer program
and Tomohiro Tachi wrote
a couple papers about it.
That program does
not always work.
Doesn't make every polyhedron.
It need some finesse to make it
work, but it's super efficient.
And it's practical.
He's made lots of models
with it like the bunny
you've seen on the poster.
There's the algorithm,
which we developed together.
And we know it's similar.
And we know it always works.
But it's a little
bit less practical.
So it's-- theory's always
a little behind practice,
let's say.
So there's a
practical thing here.
There's also a theoretically
guaranteed thing here.
They're not quite the same,
but they're very similar.
I'm going to tell you a little.
I'll show you both, basically.
But the idea is, a
practical algorithm
to fold any polyhedron.
And practical here
is a bit vague.
We don't-- that's not a theorem.
We don't know how to define
practical in mathematics
anyway.
It has some fun features,
though, mathematically.
One is that it's seamless.
So for it to be seamless, I
need to assume convex faces.
So faces are the sides
of the polyhedron.
So like in a cube,
every face is a square.
Those are convex.
And provided all the faces
are convex, if they're not,
you have to cut them
up into convex pieces.
My folding will be
seamless in that
it will be covered by an
entire piece of paper.
There maybe other things
hidden underneath.
But there won't be any
visible seems on the top side.
So that's nice.
It's also water tight.
And for this, I have
an illustration.
This is a feature missed
by the strip method.
And if you've always
felt like the strip
method of making
anything is cheating,
here's a nice formal sense
in which it's cheating.
We didn't realize it until we
start talking about Origamizer
which does not have
this cheating sense.
So here I'm trying to
make a 3D surface, looks
like a saddle
surface, by a strip.
If I just visited the guys in
this nice zigzag order, which
I know is possible, I get all
these slits down the sides.
This thing would not hold water.
If you poured water
on it, it would
fall through all the cracks.
And if I fold it right,
like in this picture,
there should be
no seems in here.
The square, the boundary of the
squares is what's drawn in red.
So here the boundary
of your piece of paper
gets mapped all over the place.
So it's lots of holes.
Here, I want the
boundary of the paper
to be the same as the
boundary of the surface.
So the only place the water
to run off is at the edge.
I mean, obviously, this
thing is not a closed solid.
But if you actually
made a cube, you're
still going to get some
edge because the boundary
paper has to go somewhere.
But if you then
sewed up the edge,
it would totally hold water.
So that is the informal
version of watertight.
The formal version
is the boundary
of the paper maps within
some tiny distance
epsilon of the boundary
of the surface, boundary
of the polyhedron.
And here, when I say
polyhedron, I really
means something that's
topologically a disk.
Brief topology.
This is a disk.
This is not a disk.
Cube is not a disk.
It's a sphere.
This is a disk.
A piece of paper is a disk.
So really the only things
you could fold topologically
in a pure sense in a water
tight sense are disks.
You can't glue things together.
That's not in the rules.
So I can't make--
I could fold this.
But I'd have to have
an extra seem somewhere
in order to make this
thing just be a disk.
I could fold a cube.
But I have to have
some seem somewhere.
Here-- the top-- a square
gets cut into four pieces
in order to make it into a disk.
Any higher topology can be
cut down and made a disk.
So this is still universal.
But in terms of the
water tightness,
you have to think
about the disk version.
AUDIENCE: Erik?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Even when you go
back and forth with the script
method, you could argue that
that was topologically a disk.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Anything, any folding you make
is still topologically a disk.
This is making a disk.
But it's doesn't
preserve the boundary.
AUDIENCE: It what?
PROFESSOR: It's not
preserving the boundary.
So yeah.
Any origami, you're
still disk like,
and you're watertight
for some disk surface.
But I want to make this disk
surface with that boundary.
And watertightness is supposed
to match the given boundary.
But that boundary
must form a disk.
That's the point.
I can't say, oh, there's
no boundary in a cube.
So you have-- so the boundary
of paper goes nowhere.
That's not allowed.
So you get to specify it,
but it has to be a disk.
I'm going to wave
my hand some more.
There's another feature which
you can see in this picture.
This is a schematic of what
Origamizer would produce which
is that there's some
extra stuff underneath.
It's slightly lighter because
it's on the bottom side there.
But you can see
along every edge,
these are the edges of
the actual polyhedron.
And then, there's these
extra little tabs,
extra flaps on the underside.
This is actually necessary.
If you want
watertightness, you can't
fold exactly that polyhedron.
You fold a slightly
thickened version.
But you can keep all
those flaps on one side.
So if you're making
something like a cube,
you can put all the
garbage on the inside
where no one can see it.
So there's another feature
here is we get a little extra.
And that's necessary if
you want watertightness.
And it's sort of
the trick that makes
all of this possible
and efficient and so on.
So the high level
idea of Origamizer
is we're going to say,
there's all these faces
that we need to make.
So just plop them down on
the piece of paper somewhere.
And then, fold away the excess.
Get rid of it by tucking.
And that excess
paper is going to get
mapped into these
little chunks here.
And maybe I'll show you a demo.
So you takes
something like-- this
is similar to the
thing I was showing.
And I forgot a mouse.
There are all the
faces in the plane.
And they've conveniently
already been arranged.
I can't zoom out because
I lack scroll wheel.
But there's a square
that makes the-- yeah,
or a multi-touch trackpad.
Sorry.
And all the faces
are just there.
And then there's
this extra stuff.
And now I say-- I should
probably do this, too.
Maybe not.
Well, all right.
And then I say, crease pattern.
Boom.
That folds away the excess.
And then, just the
white faces, these guys
which correspond faces
over there, are used.
And then, you just fold
away the extra junk.
Easy.
You want to make a bunny.
This is actually
an example where
it will not work by itself.
Because as I said,
this algorithm
is not quite guaranteed to work.
So I'm going to change
the boundary little bit
by cutting to the ears.
And so this is still--
it was a disk before.
It's a disk after because
there's this boundary here.
But it turns out,
now the algorithm
will work, assuming
I didn't mess up.
It's bouncing
around a little bit.
You can see it's
pretty efficient here.
There's very tiny gaps
between the triangles.
There's actually a little
bit a violation here.
What's happening, which you
can see here, is, on the inside
are all this extra
structure, these flaps.
And sometimes they're so
big that they actually
penetrate the surface.
But that can be dealt with by
just a little bit of cutting,
maybe a little more cutting.
Not cutting in
the literal sense.
But we just subdivided
these panels
into lots of smaller panels.
And now, it is valid.
This not the design that
you've seen on the poster.
The design on poster's
little more efficient.
I'm not so expert.
I'm not so pro that I can
make exactly that design.
So it's a little inefficient
on the sides here.
But you can use this tool
to make super complicated 3D
models.
Let me quickly tell you what
goes into the algorithm.
So the first part
is to figure out
where all these tucks
are going to go.
They lie essentially
along angular bisectors
on one side of every edge.
But at the vertices, things
are super complicated.
And in general, if you have a
non-convex surface with tons
of material coming together,
what I'd like to do
is add lots of little
flaps on the side.
So that when I
open it up-- so let
me draw you a generic picture.
So we have two faces
coming together.
What I'd like to do
is add a flap here
and a corresponding
one just behind it.
So that's sort of a tab.
And I can unfold that and
think of some other surface
that I'm trying to fold.
So I really wanted just
those two polygons.
But now, I've made some other
thing which is still a disk.
You can add those faces in
such a way that you will have,
at most, 360 degrees
of material everywhere.
So even though in
the original thing,
you had maybe tons of material
coming together which you
cannot make with real paper,
you add in a bunch of tabs along
the edges and a few
more at the vertices.
You can fix things so
that the thing is actually
makeable from one
sheet of paper.
That's the high level idea.
Doing that is a bit detailed.
The paper isn't even published.
These are some figures from it.
But this is some--
way this is how
you resolve a vertex with
some triangulation stuff.
Each of these corresponds to
a flap in the original thing.
And then, this is where
we're a little impractical.
It doesn't quite
match what we do
in practice in the
computer program.
But the idea is, you imagine,
you have your faces which
you want to bring
together somehow.
They're distributed in the
piece of paper somewhere.
But you'd really like
to connect them together
when they have matching edges.
So this edge might
be glued to some edge
of some other triangle.
And I need to just navigate
these little river-like strips
to visit one edge
from the other.
And we proved that if these
guys are sufficiently tiny,
you can always do that.
And of course, in reality,
you want to arrange things,
so you can do it efficiently
with little wastage.
But we proved at least it's
possible with this kind
of wiggly path stuff.
So now our picture, the
thing we're trying to make
looks something like that.
Where we have-- originally
it was four triangles,
the gray triangles.
We added in these extra
flaps so that it's
nice and well-behaved.
And each of those flaps we're
covering from both sides.
And if you think the red
diagram-- I'll get this right.
The red diagram
corresponds to that.
It's just been kind of squashed.
So there are four
triangles, which
correspond to the
four top flaps.
And there's this outer chunk
which corresponds to that flap.
And then, you look at the dual
which is the blue diagram.
You take that
picture, and that's
how you set up the crease
pattern essentially.
So these are the
original four triangles.
And then.
There's all this
stuff that represents
the structure of that
thing that we want to make.
And then, you just have to fill
in the creases in the middle.
And you do that just
with something--
this is how you do it
guaranteed correct.
And we saw I had to do
lots of subdivision here.
What I called,
accidentally, cutting.
But just lots of pleats there.
Because, essentially,
this is the edge.
And we want that edge to
lie in a tiny little tab.
So it's got to go up
and down and up and down
and up and down,
accordion style.
And if you do it
right, all those things
will collapse down to
a little tab attached
to that edge which is
also attach that edge.
And they will get joined up.
Then, you've got to get rid of
all this stuff in the middle.
And rough idea is,
if you pack it with--
or I guess you
cover it with disks
so that everything
is again very tiny.
And you fold what's called the
[INAUDIBLE] with those points.
And it works.
It's a complicated
but very cool.
And the paper hopefully will
be released later this year
finally.
And that's Origamizer.
And that's efficient
origami design.